welcome back this is the Ben Shapiro
show we are taking your calls at eight
five five two three six thirty two
twenty eight eight five five two three
six thirty two twenty eight Billy in
Kansas you're on the bench be Rochelle
go for Billy oh hello Ben
hey I want to say I'm a big fan of yours
I've been listening your cue for about
three years now and I can't hate the
work you do yeah yeah well first of all
thank you thank you for thank you for
listening even though you disagree like
I think it's a really an important thing
for the country it's why I always urge
people to listen on the right to listen
to some left-wing chose to do so I
appreciate that yeah yeah I agree with
that too
my question for you today is what is the
conservative solution to the student
debt crisis so as you know right now
there's a whole generation of people
Millennials like us who are brain Watson
to thinking that causes a pathway for
success when in actuality there's only a
few worthwhile majors in my opinion to
get into whether it is oh yeah what the
debt one a half trillion dollars it's
crippling our generation and Mike
the economy in general in the
future as Millennials are foregoing or
delaying things like homeownership
getting married starting a family
starting a new business and businesses
and etc I know you believe in you know
all those things being a good thing
what is the conservative solution to our
balloony crisis okay well I don't think
that the solution is as Democrats and
some Republicans have suggested that the
taxpayers ought to pick up the bill I
don't think that it's my responsibility
I paid off my student debt I don't think
it's my responsibility to pick up
somebody else's student debt I
particularly don't think it's somebody's
responsibility who never went to college
to pick up somebody else's student debt
I think that there are really two
questions with regard to the student
debt crisis one is not a going-forward
basis and one is what do we do with the
people who already have student debt so
let's handle the second one first or
rather the first one first because on
the going-forward basis the answer is
that there are a few different things
that have been proposed one is that you
could basically say to colleges not
through the legislature but simply
through students saying this that we are
not going to go to college unless we
unless you effectively guarantee us a
certain level of income coming out right
there's no point in me spending this
much money on less I think there's a
very good shot that coming out I'm going
to have this income and may there been
proposals on a legislative level to make
colleges liable for false marketing if
they suggest that you're going to be
able to make a certain amount of money
come
College and you're not actually able to
make that amount of money coming out of
college
I'm not supremely warm to that proposal
but I'm also not cold to that proposal I
think it would take some pretty specific
legislative line-drawing to do something
like that beyond that I think that
employers generally have to stop
screening employees for college
education we don't do it at the Daily
wire all right The Daily wire my
business partner didn't graduate from
college and so we've had a proposal
since the beginning of policy that we do
not look at your college education
when you come into the office because we
don't think that that's a good gauge of
whether you will be a good employee or
not right there there are other ways of
doing it there there are also laws that
are on the books that are very stupid
that ban people from giving sort of
employment tests like sort of a quasi
SAT for employment and and those laws
are very dumb because honestly what it
causes people to do is go participate in
what we call credentialing right they
will go and they will they will get a
degree just to prove that they have a
high IQ as opposed to if we just knew
they had a high IQ you wouldn't have to
spend four years getting in the degree
so I'm going forward basis it has to be
a ground shifting idea on how we deal
with college we should be encouraging
people to use online education we should
be encouraging people to major in the
hard sciences as opposed to majoring in
the liberal arts and we should be
encouraging people to take on
apprenticeships as opposed to going to
college in the first place okay now as
to the people who have racked up student
loan debt and they did so you know ten
years ago five years ago and they're not
paying it back properly I mean the
answer there is that typically the the
amount that you are paying on your
student loan debt you can carry for
quite a while before you start getting
hit with major charges I know this
because I did carry student loan debt
for a while and the interest rate was
very very low and for probably the first
ten years that the student loan debt
existed I think that unfortunately if
you take out a loan you're responsible
for the loan and I don't think that the
government should be bailing out major
corporations I don't think that the
government should be bailing out Wall
Street I don't think the government
should be bailing out individuals who
take out loans to go to college it's the
going forward problem I think that is
more telling I think as far as people
who are in current debt crisis right now
if you have a prospect at good
employment coming up there are going to
be people who are able to consolidate
loans
some of them advertise on this program I
just don't I fundamentally disagree with
the idea that if you take out a loan for
something then it doesn't pay off for
you that it's the responsibility of
society to assume the cost of the loan
okay I don't know how much time we got
but I was 34 public
education control so I am for localized
public education if a local community
wishes to undertake it I'm not for
federally subsidized public education
and I think that the idea of having laws
that basically require that parents
educate their children is another way of
going about that meaning that you have
to enroll your kid in a school you have
to make sure that your kids have a
baseline of education otherwise you are
participating in in the their election
of your children but making it so that
we have to have the federal government
run federal education has been a
complete fail from beginning to end
it also neglects the fact that's a real
problem in education the real present no
one will talk about this of course but
the real problem in education typically
is not a problem of underfunded schools
it is typically a problem of parents or
parents strategy and inability of
parents to make sure that their kids are
able to get a proper education tossing
money in our public schools and gonna
fix that and federalizing it ain't gonna
fix that Billy I really appreciate the
call sangeun Atlanta Georgia you're on
the bench Peter I shall go for its Angie
Hayes and just want to say I'm super a
huge fan of your show and thank you for
everything that you do so a major thing
that I have the issue as it in a way
that every single time I try to use like
a lot of stats that you use such as like
from the Brookings Institute like you
know the three ways that you can there's
a 98% chance you're not in poverty etc
whatever may be any sort of like facts /
feelings debate it's basically like all
my friends will always take the
emotional appeal and say that I'm being
insensitive because I don't understand
everyone's individual situation where
I'm like generalizing and basically
they'll say like I'm coming from a
privileged point of view and I'd only
know how to respond to that sometimes
because I like I want to I personally
think that America out of any other
country has the most opportunities and
there's a less like this country that
has the least external barriers um and I
don't you know maybe I might be
privileged I know for sure my parents
aren't so like how do I don't really
respond to that and kind of talk about
the economic mobility and how the fact
that people can actually you know work
their way up regardless of circumstances
from a more emotional appeal right so I
think that's answer there is that you
have to start off with the basic premise
and the basic premise is are we allowed
to have a conversation that is apart
from empathy meaning that are we light
how is this conversation about me
empathizing with
your problems or is this a problem
there's this conversation about
solutions I've said on the program many
times I actually have this deal with my
own wife right I mean in a marriage very
often what happens that you're talking
to your spouse and your spouse just
wants to wants you to hear them right
they just want to explain what their
emotions are and instead you're like
yeah here's a solution they get angrier
at you when you propose a solution
because what they actually want you to
do is empathize well I actually have a
deal with my wife which is I will say to
her at the beginning of a conversation
do you want me to empathize with you or
do you want me to help you solve the
problem and she'll to her credit give me
an actual answer to that so when it
comes to political conversation we have
to start from the premise that this
isn't about empathy this is about
solving the problem so if you want me to
empathize with your position full
empathy I feel bad for you I'm sorry
that you've had to deal with what you've
had to go through like my heart really
goes out to you that doesn't solve the
problem so now let's talk about solving
the problem because what the dumbest
point of view here is that politics is
motivated by empathy that's not true
okay political solutions are not
motivated by level of empathy you can be
the least empathetic person in the world
and if you offer a better political
solution it's a better political
solution the logic should stand on its
own it's not the most caring person who
ought to be president it's the person
who actually knows how to solve a
problem right you don't look for the
most empathetic plumber right if you if
you called up your plumber and you said
yeah my pipes are clogged and toilets
backing up and he's like god I feel so
bad for you that's just awful it's it's
really terrible for you isn't you like
what the hell like you're a plumber what
do you I don't need your empathy I need
you to come over here and unclog the
pipe when you're talking politics
empathy is is virtually never supremely
useful it is useful in politicking but
it is not useful in finding political
solutions and that has to be made clear
at the outside of the conversation
sounds you really appreciate the call
let's heat add in Fort Lauderdale
Florida you're on the bench appear on
trial go for it sad I just requested for
a very very experienced to see the
division in America and the political
maneuvering of the radical left and it's
clear the Democrats don't have a same
candidate I wanted to know what your
thoughts are if the Democrats were to
win and keep the house maybe even take
the Senate and then the other question I
have is do you think that this trend
towards the left will continue with
younger generations I continue to be
disillusioned by what I see amongst the
Millennials and I'm I'm hoping that we
have a
writer future with some sanity you know
Ted I've seen some conflicting
statistics in terms of the last question
I've seen some conflicting statistics on
whether young people will grow out of
the the sort of ridiculous socialistic
insanity that they've bought into some
of that is is delayed because people are
living in their parents houses longer
they're getting married later they're
paying taxes later it's not maybe
there's just a longer delay effect but
it's sort of hard to see a radical
shifts happening among Millennials
although if the Left pushes too far
failure does have a way of drawing
blowback right and Great Britain Great
Britain had moved very far to the left
in the aftermath of World War two and
then there's a complete collapse of the
economy in the 1970s that's how Margaret
Thatcher ends up as President Ronald
Reagan ends up as president after two
decades of radical left ISM from the
federal government so there can be a
backlash to failure as far as the
concern about the divisions between
Democrats and Republicans what happens
if Democrats win and win the house and
the Senate
well then disaster sets in I think that
the first thing the Democrats probably
do is they move toward some version of
more nationalized health care I think
they probably are able to cobble
together the votes or something along
those lines probably a medicare-for-all
option right the sort of Budaj edge
version of medicare for all which in
effect the public option bankrupts the
the private sector that is the goal of
the public option in the first place and
then continues to draw taxpayer dollars
and centralize it I think you will see a
dramatic shift in foreign policy a
dramatic downgrading of the United
States military which has happened for
every Democratic president it's all of
this is deeply troubling radically
higher taxes every single Democrat has
proposed radically higher taxes and
those taxes will have to drip down to
the middle class because there's no way
to grab the money from the rich people
only so yeah I mean all of this is scary
Ted and it's why the radicalization of
the Democratic Party is bad it's why I
keep saying and all the people rooting
for Bernie Sanders to be the nominee
don't do it don't root for Bernie
Sanders to be the nominee because that's
an awful that's an awful risk you're
taking right yeah it did like if Bernie
Sanders the president I'm not sure
that's worth the risk of him being the
candidate so dad really appreciate the
call we'll take more of your calls in
just a moment at eight five five two
three six 32:28 first let me explain to
you something about me I'm a unique
fellow with a unique body and that means
that I need a unique mattress and I have
one it is my helix sleep mattress it is
built just for me and they can build a
mattress just for you it is supremely
comfortable
he likes sleep his bill to quiz it takes
two minutes to complete they use the
answers to match her body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress for
you if you like a mattress that's really
soft or firm if you sleep on your side
or your back or your stomach if you
sleep really hot with helix there's a
specific mattress for each and
everybody's unique it tastes like my
specific that I tend to like a firmer
mattress just go to helix sleep comm
slash Apparel they will match you to a
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life I sleep on a helix
mattress if you don't if you but you
don't need to take my word for it you
get a helix sleep mattress yourself it
is incredibly good I know because I use
one my wife uses one and so good I got
one for my sister for her wedding
everything is made right here in America
they've got a 10 year warranty you get
to try it out for a hundred nights
risk-free which is an excellent deal if
you try helix sleep and you don't like
it they pick it up for you right now no
problem right now helix is offering up
to 200 bucks off mattress orders which
is a great deal and up to 200 bucks off
at helix sleep comm slash repair we live
in the age of personalization why not
personalize that mattress and up to 200
bucks off at helix sleep comm slash
Shapiro Alex in Houston you're on the
bench pirogue Lauren Alex have been so
long time listener a recent subscriber
but I was wondering it seems like every
week or so you come out with this new
disaster story about California so
outside of a catastrophic event you know
someone dumping a bucket of hot B C's on
ducks sparrows head or their kids W on
exposed needle how bad would things in
California have to get before you start
looking up houses in Texas who says I
have been looking up house in Texas my
man I've been searching Zillow yeah I
will tell you there are other areas of
the United States that do not have any
13.3% top tax rate and have open feces
on the street so I will say that the the
draw of California is not strong enough
to justify the way the state is run and
I will say that I in all candor the it
is not going to take much more to drive
me from this state I mean in reality so
I can't if the state continues along as
meth I cannot imagine I'm living here
five to ten years from now I just can't
imagine it's almost impossible to learn
that being the case Alex and I just
remember it yeah sorry go for it during
the daily the back stays alive dot king
lowercase T lowercase K boring said that
they were staying in California because
they do their best to work for behind
relined or whatever yeah and I mean that
that is the best excuse to be here even
that excuse starts to look a lot less
nice when it's when there is a homeless
person on every single bench in the city
where I grew up and open needles as you
mentioned on the street where my
children play so all that tends to go by
the wayside plus I think that we can be
fairly solid conservative him have spent
35 years behind enemy lines that seems
like a lot to learn about the about the
left I appreciate the call Jeremy in
Michigan you're on the bench Bureau
shadow for Jeremy hello Ben
I was wondering how we could incorporate
constitutional principles into education
to to better educate the public to see
when you know they're trying to move the
lever of let's say like public safety to
override or right or to overcome it or
to restrict it beyond what there's most
well Jeremy I appreciate the call I
think that when it comes to you know
invoking constitutional principles and
teaching them I will admit I do have a
book coming out it is all about the
foundations of the United States what it
will take to unify us and what those
foundational principles are that's
coming out in July so take a look out on
Amazon for it will probably be in
pre-release fairly soon Jeremy really
appreciate the call Christian in Salt
Lake City Utah you're on the bed Shapiro
sure though for a Christian hi then
thanks for having me on
sure so my question here is given the
door legalization of same-sex marriage
and your position that the government's
entirely which I personally agree with
you think that the state has a business
in continuing to make polygamy illegal
even me being the multi person marriage
between a consenting adult so I actually
believe that the government should stay
at the government effectively does stay
out of this now I mean if you think that
people aren't living in polyamory right
now they are right I mean it's not
illegal to live in polyamory having
people legalize that by contract
it seems to me having the government
approve it is horrible I don't think the
government should be approving it and
treating it as marriage but then again I
don't think that the government should
be approving and treating as marriage
same-sex marriage right I was against
the government approval of same-sex
marriage I think the government should
be entirely out of this business
altogether I don't think that the
government has any role to play when it
comes to sanctifying marriage or talking
about how people should live together I
think it's the government's role to
ensure that we don't hurt each other I
don't think it's the government's role
to play sort of moral imprimatur for
particular activity I think that is the
job of your church and your
neighbourhood so yeah I mean first of
all as we say like right now it is not
illegal right now if you go down to your
local weird Church and you have them
marry all seven of you you're not gonna
be prosecuted for that and any state in
the Union it's when you try to file a
joint tax return you got a problem
obviously Christian really appreciate it
they call already coming up we'll take
more of your calls at eight five five to
thirty six thirty to twenty eight you're
listening to the Ben Shapiro show